she gonna open your gift
eat it now monster the Jeffrey Dahmer
story is here and it's causing a big
splash this Netflix release seemed to
show up unannounced and viewers are
divided on their opinions of the show
what was director Ryan Murphy's one rule
When approaching this kind of a story
and how did Evan Peters even begin
preparing for such a dark role stick
around to find out the Jeffrey Dahmer
story is is so much bigger than than
just him
number one Dahmer actor Evan Peters said
sort of started with a blank slate with
Dahmer Peters only had a few images in
mind before he began his journey into
filming this story which might be why it
took some time before he agreed to play
the title role to help Evans prepare and
maybe even to convince him to sign on to
the Project Director Ryan Murphy sent
Evan the script with some other
materials to help him learn more about
Dahmer Evan said but in order to do that
I was gonna have to go to really dark
places and stay there for an extended
period of time
number two right into the deep end after
looking carefully through the background
material sent to him by director Ryan
Murphy Evan Peters probably felt a
strange kind of inspiration this is the
kind of sensitive storytelling that he'd
want to get just right and doing that
meant learning about the details of what
Dahmer did and trying to understand the
motivation behind the Killer's decisions
this is a grim task that would
definitely have a psychological toll on
even the most seasoned actors Peter said
commit to that was a absolutely going to
be one of the hardest things I've ever
had to do in my life number three just
one it can be useful to have a mission
statement and this seemed to prove true
once again on the set of Dahmer with
director Ryan Murphy's one rule for the
production in a Netflix interview actor
Evan Peters talks about how the director
wanted to approach this sensitive story
we had one rule going into this uh from
from Ryan that it would never be told
from Dahmer's point of view you this
lines up with a subtle focus on all the
other characters portrayed in the show
you might notice that the stories with
the most detail are those of the people
Dahmer affected rather than Dahmer
himself Peters also says that as an
audience you're not really sympathizing
with him you're not really getting into
his plight you're more sort of watching
it number four you might notice first on
the Netflix
chilling visual Evan Peters wore yellow
contacts for the role while we might be
accustomed to alarming choices like this
on screen we're surprised to learn
through the characters on-screen
explanation that Dahmer had a real life
fascination with yellow eyes in the
second episode when Dahmer anticipates
conorack in his apartment the victim
wakes up in Dahmer's lap to everyone's
surprise Dahmer is wearing yellow
contacts he explains that they're like
the Emperors in Star Wars Episode 4
Return of the Jedi
number five it seems the making of this
show wasn't just for entertainment it
might also have been for telling the
stories of all those people affected by
Dahmer and his acts this seems to have
been director Ryan Murphy's approach and
we can hear hints of it through the
actors involved in the production actor
Richard Jenkins who plays Dahmer's
father said this about director Ryan
Murphy's approach to the work Ryan used
to be a journalist and it's really
thorough an investigation not just of
Dahmer but the damage that he caused to
the victims and their families and to
his parents number six it wasn't super
cheery
in one of a few videos from on set we
see a near expressionless Evan Peters in
his Dahmer costume and hair leaving them
all with a camera rolling in front of
him the moment feels plain and Bleak was
this the feeling on set all the time we
hope not there is some hope though after
Penelope Miller played Dahmer's mother
on the show and was one of the few to
post some photos from the set on her
socials Penelope described working with
actor Evan Peters in her post I beyond
loved working with him and even though
Jeffrey and Joyce Dahmer had a strained
and estranged relationship in the true
story We secretly wished we had more to
do together he is a consummate actor and
I adore him so it can't have been all
bad you haven't had a nice word for me
in years you're always in your room
you don't want a mother you don't want
me number seven this one's for you
Glenda actor Niecy Nash talks about how
they decided to dedicate a part of the
show to the character of Glenda
Cleveland one of the surviving victims
Glenda did a lot in real life but not
many people who are aware of the story
know that much about her Niecy
discovered while working on Dahmer that
Glenda regularly reported Dahmer to the
police in real life and no one really
heeded her warnings misi expressed a
very pivotal moment
and see the family of this baby she
tried to help she wonders if it all
could have been prevented if the police
had listened to Glenda at least in this
show her work actually got recognized
number eight how do you get into the
state of mind to play Someone Like
Jeffrey Dahmer on film if you ask the
actor Evan Peters he might say research
and then proceeded to
read
biographies Peter seems to have delved
deep into the behavior of this character
saying Dahmer is interesting and that he
is almost regretful and has guilt and
sort of confusion about what went on he
doesn't really have a Charming
mischievous smile he is docile sort of
aloof and almost disassociated from what
he did Peters adds that during his
research he found the way that Dahmer
spoke was very candid and very normal
again it was so jaw-dropping that it all
really happened number nine before
signing on to the project Peters was
sent the scripts by director Ryan Murphy
Murphy also sent him recommendations to
learn more about the story and even some
things that might have convinced Peters
to care more deeply about why this story
was worth telling Peter said that it's
called the Jeffrey Dahmer story but it's
not just him and his backstory it's the
repercussions this is how society and
our system failed to stop him multiple
times number 10 this show needed it we
can only imagine the undertaking of such
a role would be a daunting task and it
seems that Evan Peters had a team to
help him through it Peters describes
working closely with some crew members
who went above and beyond their
production roles to help him maintain
his mental health I have to say that the
crew was instrumental in keeping me on
the guardrails I cannot thank them
enough and I could not have done any of
this role without them specifically
Sarah our Focus puller who is just such
a breath of fresh air and light when we
were filming some of these horrific
scenes Jason RDP who kept reminding me
of why we were doing it number 11.
stories as horrifying as these can often
leave us wondering why they are worth
telling Dahmer actor Evan Peters had to
do some careful consideration around
portraying the role and here's what he
came up with it felt important to be
respectful to the victims to the victims
families to try to tell the story as
authentically as we could you need to
have certain plot points because he did
do these things but you don't need to
embellish them you know we get it you
know we don't need to see it over and
over again number 12. the release of the
show has seen some content from behind
the scenes and we expect that what we
didn't expect was just how little we've
seen of the making of and behind the
scenes moments that normally would come
with building the hype of a new release
the cast hasn't really spoken too much
to the Press about the series media was
not granted access to previews of the
show and there was no Premiere either we
wonder if this was a clever but reverent
decision by Netflix to both build
mystery and Intrigue around the show but
also to treat the sensitive topic with a
degree of respect it is a story about
genre but is also a story about the
victims it seems like the show took
great care in telling this story
reminding each other daily of the one
rule of putting this show on and why it
was a story worth telling what are your
thoughts on the making of the show do
you think you would have enjoyed a day
on set why or why not let us know in the
comments below